- This is a grocery packing warehouse
in the south-east of London.
Folks have ordered their groceries online,
and instead of people walking
up and down the aisles of a
traditional grocery store to pick up items,
these little devices move more than
a million items every day between them.
Instead of trying to build machines
that fit into a world designed for humans,
this entire facility, the size
of seven football fields,
is custom-built to make this
as efficient as possible.
I cannot get across on camera
just how incredibly large
this whole place is.
The top speed of those boxes
is about 14 kilometres an hour
and they pass within five millimetres
of each other when they move.
So: how many robots are there
in the Hive?
Well, that depends on how you count them.
- What you're looking at
behind me is the Hive.
We've got the grid, which
is the metal structure,
it's filled with products,
so that product is housed
within what we call totes
or these open boxes that you can see
at the top of the grid.
We have around 2,300 bots
and they move the stock
around the warehouse,
so that we can pair it up with
customer orders to be delivered.
The bots will move in
the X and Y direction,
they can also move in the Z direction.
So we have a cable hoist system.
That means that they can
lower down a gripper assembly
and grab onto the stock
that we have in the grid.
In some areas we have as deep
as 21 totes, all in a line.
We have sensors underneath the bot,
that mean that every time it passes
over one of the squares on the grid,
it has a laser underneath it,
that can tell when it
moves over that cell.
So it will say "I passed a cell,
I passed a cell, I passed a cell."
We have around 58,000 different types
of individual products within the grid.
We'll use the huge amounts
of data that we gather
to understand what customers
are most likely to order
and place them in the easiest
to reach locations for bots.
All of that combined means
that we can have stock
into the warehouse and out
again from our suppliers,
into a delivery van,
in just five hours.
- The robots deliver their crates
over to the packing area.
Some of that packing is done by humans,
but there are mechanical arms as well.
One of the big problems
they've got to solve
is that grocery packaging
is designed for people,
and the interactions
between all the objects
they deal with can be...
complicated.
- Currently, we're standing
underneath the grid structure
that we saw earlier.
The robots that we saw
are actually dropping off
products to the station.
Once they're dropped off,
they become in control of the robot
and the robot decides how to pick them,
before the grid robot picks up their tote
and takes it away again.
There's two 3D cameras above the totes,
so it takes an image of the storage box
before it picks from it
decides on the best grasp point,
confirm that the product is correct,
and then place it into
a customer's shopping
and it's doing all of that
on live customer orders.
We make sure that we don't
mix something that was heavy
with something that's soft.
There are things that
the robot can't pack,
things such as very, very heavy,
very large or very fragile items,
but there's a lot of
range in between that.
- It's fairly safe to call each
individual packing arm "a robot".
Each one has a
separate controller
and it has to make a lot
of decisions in real time
using cameras and sensors
on each individual arm.
But here in the Hive,
it's not quite as simple.
- Controlling all of this is what
we refer to as the Hive Mind,
so this artificial intelligence system
that controls everything.
Once the stock comes in,
from that exact point
that it enters the system,
the Hive Mind will track
its every single movement.
The Hive Mind will tell the bots
exactly where they need to stop,
but it is the bot's control system
that allows it to follow
a movement profile
and stop exactly as the
hive mind expects it to.
There's just a 5mm gap
between bots,
so that's both as they pass each other
and if they stop next to a bot as well.
This bot with the orange light
may have experienced
something within its sensors
and all of those readings it's taking,
that when it feeds that
back to the Hive Mind,
it's not quite what the
Hive Mind was expecting,
so it just brings it to a
safe stop for investigation.
We do have a number of grid operators
that sit at the edge of the grid
and they're able to use our CCTV system
that we have above the grid
to look at exactly what's
going on with that bot
and they can try and fix that remotely
and send commands to the bot wirelessly.
- The boundary between "individual"
and "group" is a little blurry.
Is a termite colony a collection of
individuals working together,
or one big superorganism?
Is the microbiome in
your gut part of you?
Because in the last couple of decades
scientists have started to work out
that the bacteria in your digestive system
produce and consume neurotransmitters
that affect how you think.
But most people wouldn't consider
their gut bacteria to be "part of them".
We tend to ascribe
intelligence and identity
to things that act at roughly our scale.
It's easy to look at the Hive,
see the moving boxes and go,
"okay, 2000 robots".
But with only one controller
and the boxes just following
the paths they're given,
I'd say there's a good
argument that
that is one robot...
with 2,000 ways to
interact with the world.
Thank you so much to
everyone here at Ocado.
There is a link to them
and more about their
technology in the description.